well when it comes to eating more and
more people are turning to a plant-based
lifestyle to get healthy
but where can you go to ask questions
and find options it's a new vegan market
and it recently opened in the valley and
they've got answers
bianca holmen is live at vegan out
market bianca that's clever i love the
name of this place
yes clever name and they've got it all
sherry so
i'm starting to do some early morning
shopping they've got mushroom risotto
here and they even
support local vegan business owners like
todd's sauces right there again local
and it's all about supporting local
right now and so we're joined by
the owners katie and eric rogers so
katie tell us there's a lot of people
who still don't know what is the
difference between being vegan
and vegetarian yeah well vegans don't
need any dairy or eggs
all right so no animal byproducts not
even honey right
so eric tell us why was it just so
important for you all to
open up this market because there are
you know health food stores like a whole
foods or like a trader joe's but you all
only uh focus on vegan items right
right um it's just there's when you go
into a store there's always a little
section
that's going to be part beginnings you
can say okay this is vegan but
here everything's vegan and i know
there's always new products coming out
and we're trying to incorporate new
things that you haven't seen
so you might see some of the stuff that
we have here at a regular place but then
more we try to expand on that yeah you
all have so many options even this
kelly's right here
uh those who are on tick tock you know
tabitha brown she is like the queen of
veganism right now so
she mentions this they got it here but
also you all are doing some good things
in the community you all are doing a
food collection for
uh people who've been you know displaced
or you know lost their jobs
correct the lost vegan food bank with
ranch island rescue
you can drop off the donations here uh
they pick it up every week
um we actually go and help them once on
uh every every two weeks we we
try to help and um you can also fill out
a form if you're in need
fill out the form online you can go to
our website the veg in dashout.com
and fill out a form as well well that's
so good to know so again if you have
questions or you're thinking about it
you know we're always looking for ways
to get healthy and support our local
business owners
and again uh we thank them for letting
us be here this early morning
and do some food shopping but we're
gonna send it back to you guys in the
studio oh
sherry and alex they got some
gluten-free options too i would hope so
yes we'll have to shop there that's a
cool place bianca
thanks bianca yeah she told us about uh
what was it called in january uh uh the
january
yeah that's it yeah but that's such a
cool option i'm sure it's been so hard
with the pandemic
but yes then you'd have to go through
all the aisles and look at the little
print
it's a good option